fun right that's fun oh she's out of
here she'll be back
they all come back no hi guys my name is
grace Helbig if you don't know now you
know your life is different now welcome
to another video I'm excited to record a
video today and I'm going with this
energy I'm saying yes did this positive
distress and we're going with it last
time I shot a video we started with a
collective hips which I think was very
helpful for a lot of us and it was also
very confusing for a lot of our pets
which i think is also pretty helpful for
us so why don't we do that again
do with me you know you want to you know
you have to on some you know spiritual
psychological level so on the count of
three one two three I pranked you so
hard you look like a [ __ ] idiot
look at how your cats looking at you
right now just getting one two three oh
I like that I think that might become a
more regular thing for us if that's okay
with you
if it's not okay with you there's not
much to be okay with lately so let's
just go with it I'm out of breath some
therapeutically hissing that says
something we're in a onesie we did our
hair to the best of our abilities with
what we've got that's all we can do
we're doing the best with what we got
right now you guys I went on my
Instagram last week and I asked you guys
again to tell me what's going on with
you guys what have you been up to what
kind of questions do you have if you
have any what's the general feeling the
vibe etc still tired from hitting that
doesn't vote I'm also recording audio
and a separate device so like guys I
care about you and I need you to know it
we got a wide variety of responses from
you guys and first of all I want to say
thank you for sending me all of your
authentic feelings and questions and
situations and second of all I want to
say cool buddy all right here we go
just watching Cavs be born while
to do work okay is watching the calves
being born part of your work or is that
just like a fun hobby that you do
because that's different
oh is watching calves be born like a
euphemism for like is that like a
farmer's only term or something cuz
that's funny and gross if it is some
people listen to ASMR some people watch
oddly satisfying videos and you watch
calves being born now that I know
someone peripherally friends sister on
maps New Orleans saying the word
peripherally is very difficult
I realized try and say it with me on the
count of three one two three put just
peripheral peripherally peripheral
peripheral peripherally perfect this is
where we're at
my brother is being annoying AF and he
won't shut up when I'm doing homework
any tips yes what you do is you need to
gamify the situation because little
brothers and little sisters are
biologically predisposed to being
missing annoying so you have to combat
this medical trauma with a game make
little tokens or tickets out of
construction paper make four of them
hide them throughout your house and tell
your brother that if you find all of
them that he will win a prize create the
prize whatever makes the most sense that
your little brother would want to win
however number the four tickets that
you've created one two three five hide
them tell them to find all five and come
back to you for his reward we mean
mister D I'm a great big sister by the
way what's the best way to politely tell
someone their constant texts are
annoying isn't it so fun and kind of sad
that now even in quarantine we have to
become more creative with how we avoid
social situations I mean if anything
this is truly testing the limits of our
creativity which is fun one idea I have
is that you tell this person that you've
started taking some time for yourself
every day where you put your phone away
and you don't really interact with
anyone and that just giving them a heads
up in case you don't respond but for
your own well-being you're just sort of
like putting it to the side and even if
they're not doing
not like one maybe we should all be
doing that actually - it's a great
excuse and that's like psychologically
kind of gross go down that route or I
guess you could just be honest but
that's no fun creative living is a real
treat sometimes just don't like live
stream in the timeframe that you've told
them that you won't be on your phone I
pooped while taking a quiz online
humblebrag two times over good for you
it's all about importing and exporting
like a stable economy our personal
economies and Quarantine are all about
importing and exporting and you seem to
have a very steady flow with that so
congratulations stink wrinkles yeah
[ __ ] stink wrinkles is right that's a
great phrase and I want to use it for
everything this whole situation is a
stink wrinkle my armpits smell like
stink wrinkles his hair is the Cobb dam
stink wrinkle right now I love it but is
that is that a phrase that already
exists under the problematic mmm please
don't let stink wrinkles be problematic
I just give me something silly and dumb
I don't want to put stink wrinkle on
this whole situation about the ten
grapples I clean my window for the first
time in two years that great
congratulations to your neighbors you
can clearly see you masturbating oh what
a gift you've given to yourself in the
world I put on dried-up eyeliner while
blasting all-time low and then danced
alone to one direction last night I
don't know why this comet is so
poetically beautifully depressing it's
wonderful and bleak at the same time I
love it
also because dried up eyeliner sounds
like a band someone out there it's got
myspace.com sauce dried up eyeliner
while zooming with my friends I put a
dildo on my forehead and now I have a
massive bruise fun has consequences and
you learn the hard way working as
therapists from home the stressful I
want to do more art any fun prompts
kudos to you for working as a therapist
from home it's a lot of what we need
right now I've faced time with my
therapist and so I'm very appreciative
that people in that industry are still
adapting and making themselves available
for all of our mental health sakes in
terms of art that you can do let's see
the first thing that comes to my mind is
smash a plate and then see what you can
do with the broken pieces on a
metaphorical level that feels very fun
and therapeutic to do and might help but
you know alleviate some stressful
feelings and then taking those pieces
and making it into some kind of mosaic
could be really cool the other thought I
had is taking the butt of your jeans and
seeing what you could do with that
that's the bait
weird open-ended vague prompt you know
how like in the early 2000s like 90s
like bejeweled denim but pockets were a
big thing maybe now it's the time for
all of that to come back turn your pants
over look at the butt and see how you
can make it better I kind of want to do
that later today find an old pair of
jeans or shorts and see what I can do
with the butt
maybe this is the question we should be
asking ourselves every day what can we
do with the butt to make it better I
have so many ideas that just sprinted
through my head it was like a bunch of
calves being born bought a trampoline
good that's great and it makes me want
to buy a trampoline also makes me very
nervous because don't get hurt right now
is not a time to hurt yourself and a
trampoline seems very fun but also seems
very dangerous it makes me wonder about
the amount of dumb injuries that have
increased in this time of quarantine now
I want to know what's the dumbest way
you've hurt yourself in quarantine I
bump into everything all day long
yesterday I was walking in my house I do
that sometimes and the top of my toe
flicked the prongs on a cord that wasn't
plugged in and it hurts so bad I guess
I'm just lucky like that you guys I'm
sorry too young you're yuck
my 80 year old mom threw a tantrum
because she wants to go visit a family
and I told her no eighty year old woman
and tantrum in the same sentence is very
funny to me one year as a gift to my
family for Christmas and I was super
broken had just moved to New York City
after I graduated college I gifted my
family a mockumentary of them and I just
did impressions of them and film myself
like answering questions as them and I
edit it and gave it to them
and I think they liked it they couldn't
return it so so maybe try that and see
what happens also throwing a family
member that doesn't exist and just see
what your mom does harmless mischievious
fun what is the strangest thing you
witness while being in quarantine well
the other day we were driving back from
Palm Springs and Elliott and I saw
yeah if you want to hear more about that
listen to this might get weird the
podcast I do with mamrie Hart that comes
out every Wednesday it's all linked in
the description yeah
Palm Springs goes hard so many dildos
and Quarantine dildos are having a
moment
no dildos always have a moment honestly
just thinking about starting selling
foot pics for money should I yeah and
just make sure none of them are of your
feet the other day I actually said out
loud I'm [ __ ] tired of peeing I peed
so much today hey I get it I actually
said to myself out loud in the mirror
the other day we should get into
flossing a genuine sincere moment with
myself about something that we teach
four-year-olds to do maybe instead
appreciate your body for what it's
capable of doing trying to teach music
online but none of these little shits
are doing any work I mean I love that I
love a badass hard-ass music teacher
leaned into that I think if you keep
calling them little [ __ ] to their faces
maybe they'll start actually doing the
work I'm worried it won't have the
stamina for real life when we're out of
this am I the only one worried no you
are not the only one worried if worry
was a stock right now the stock market
will be fine we're all worried I have my
first ever FaceTime date on Thursday I'm
nervous
any advice quick ideas start the date
with a ski mask or like nylon stocking
over your face holding a bag of ice once
the date begins say absolutely nothing
slam the ice on the ground and then
reveal yourself and say I just wanted an
interesting way to break the ice it can
only go one way from there just fully
depressed to not have a college
graduation I know a lot of you are
missing out on some major life events
and that must be very stressful and
disheartening and discouraging however
if you want to feel like you had a
college graduation at least in my
experience with college graduation put
on a heavy robe go sit somewhere in the
direct Sun for a long time play a
YouTube video of a graduation speech
really far in the distance that you
can't really hear exactly the words that
they're saying maybe like every other
word and then
just sit there for about three to four
hours and then stand up walk to a place
grab a piece of paper and then sit back
down and go take a photo with your
parents congratulations you've had a
college graduation throw a hat in the
air and I get inside and figure out how
you gonna pay your college debt I don't
know
day eight of lockdown found out I got
cheated on by the now ex I lived with
cute damn Wow I oh you are going through
it but okay let's be a little
mischievously optimistic about this
you've been scorned by this person you
now live with this person now is your
opportunity like I've been saying to get
creative maybe start hiding the toilet
paper put a secret lock on the bathroom
put some sort of itching scenario in
some sort of underwear scenario maybe
now of a sudden you wake up to an alarm
that is a song that he absolutely hate
leave a gallon of milk in the Sun for a
little bit and then put it back in the
fridge maybe refer to him only as big
girl that's my cup dude now if you have
some extra cash laying around maybe
register his car with a personalized
license plate that says like dildos [ __ ]
ball Shakira
scrotum I know this video seems like I'm
telling you to hurt other people up but
I'm really not I'm just telling you to
have fun
I've just been drawing porn non-stop and
be watching x-files with my cat you have
so many hobbies maybe you and person get
together and you draw some foot porn
that collectively you could sell
monetize people monetize what do people
like being horny expressing art maybe
the two of you and the therapist get
together you create a little atma camera
battery just died it says if the
universe is telling me to stop it no way
what I was saying is maybe you guys in
the therapist get together and you start
making some jeans that have some like
horny looking feet drawn on the butts of
them these are I'm just spitballing here
speaking of porn talk about spitballs oh
our brain is in a weird space I've been
kind of dating
during florentine how do I even navigate
this I don't you know but because
there's no blueprint for any of this you
can do it however you want there's no
rules there's just right I would say
this is an Outback Steakhouse but it's
not because we can't go there and if no
one is able to eat the bloomin onion
does the Outback Steakhouse even exist
oh I feel like I'm thriving by living my
best life at times feel guilty and other
time you feel yeah go me I get that too
I feel guilty when I feel good which it
shouldn't be the case and I feel guilty
when I feel bad which shouldn't be the
case so maybe we just get rid of guilt
there's no guilt in quarantine
there's just trying I'm decreeing with
the power invested in me from the
internet that there is henceforth no
guilt in quarantine unless you do
something bad actually bad finishing my
first year of my ph.d program working
full-time remotely and snuggling a
toddler good for you I also hope that
the toddler you're snuggling is yours
can people tell when you're stoned I
feel like it's written all over my face
when I am oh yeah and you guys can tell
when I'm stoned because I usually just
don't post anything on the internet what
I'm super stoned I get very paranoid
that I have like a secret and all of the
tech that I have around me that can
possibly reach out to other people I see
them as real gossipy friends and I don't
want any of my little gossipy friends to
tell anyone else my secret it tells me
when you anthropomorphize the objects in
your home I've heard from my own brain
to myself
we have great talks okay those are all
the questions or comments that I've
pulled for this video hope you guys had
fun here I had a great time getting a
little weird and sassy with you let me
know how all those harmless mischievous
well-meaning pranks go for you guys and
give me ideas for other such things that
we can do collectively as a group cuz
we're all in this together and we're all
gonna get through this together and it's
gonna be okay and if it's not okay
that's okay and that's all I can say if
you guys like this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to this YouTube
channel I'm trying to post more fun
content to give us all a little break
from all the you
no and don't forget that I got three
podcasts going on right now not too deep
on Mondays this might get weird with
mamrie on Wednesdays and pile it on
podcast with Elliott on Fridays where we
talking about all the [ __ ] that we're
watching on TV and we dive a little too
deep into our own personal analysis of
it also on my Instagram every Wednesday
there's a little series called real
house why where I show Elliott's on my
favorite moments from the Real
Housewives and we see if there's a
bigger lesson that we can learn from
these situations it's very educational
other than that I don't know I truly
don't at all whatsoever if you know you
probably don't the city's spoken thus it
is done thus we've lost a bit of our
sanity and thus it is okay because this
is thus a situation in the that we
betwixt our reality and our sanity No